we begin this morning with president
biden in poland and preparing to get a
first-hand look at the human toll of
russia's war against ukraine the united
nations estimates more than a thousand
civilians have been killed and at least
1600 others were wounded in the besieged
southern port city of mary opal this
includes 300 people in an attack on the
theater that was being used as a bomb
shelter and had the word children
written in big letters on the ground
outside this morning mr biden dropped in
on a meeting between secretary of state
lincoln
defense secretary austin and their
ukrainian counterparts on friday the
president thanked members of the 82nd
airborne who are part of nato's eastern
front poland has taken in a majority of
the nearly four million people who have
fled russia's invasion today mr biden
plans to meet with some of them nancy
cordes is traveling with the president
and begins our coverage in warsaw nancy
good morning
good morning to you jeff a somewhat
extraordinary meeting taking place here
in warsaw this morning president biden
at his hotel sitting down with the
ukrainian foreign minister the ukrainian
defense minister who left their country
overnight to travel here to warsaw about
130 miles from the border so that the
president could hear firsthand what they
need and how the u.s can help
real-time diplomacy between the leader
of the free world and leaders of a
war-torn nation
with 9 000 u.s troops now stationed in
poland president biden came to thank
them and prepare them for what could be
a prolonged mission on nato's eastern
flank
you're the finest fighting force in the
history of the world the 82nd airborne
is stationed in jeshaf poland providing
humanitarian aid in a town that has now
become a processing point for tens of
thousands of refugees the ukrainian
border is just 50 miles away they will
not let me understandably i guess it
cross the border and
take a look what's going on
in ukraine the russian strategy appears
to be shifting
pentagon officials say they see signs
that russia is bringing in more troops
from a russian occupied region of nearby
georgia
and they say the russian military is no
longer advancing towards kiev pentagon
press secretary john kirby why do you
think they're doing that well it's hard
to know it could be a negotiating tactic
maybe he wants to secure more ground
where he already has been fighting now
for eight years
so that he can gain leverage at the
negotiating table we're not sure
today on president biden's last day in
europe he is meeting with ukrainian
refugees he'll also deliver a speech for
hundreds here in warsaw and his aides
say he wants to not only show support
for poland and ukraine but also here in
eastern europe cast this conflict as a
broader battle between democracy and
autocracy jeff
nancy cordes thank you very much in
warsaw poland